so it starts off nice and gentle right
let's not jump to the answer let's get
some methods for how to solve these what
might be the first slide you right after
question would after the question so on
anyone any takers what are we looking
for para numbers right what are the
period up is gonna do we want them to
add to fall and multiply two three right
and so clearly the example with you know
B's what a three so I can write down
this factorization and from there I can
simply read the solutions remembering if
you've got come in grab save it that's
okay if you've got a pair of numbers
this one at this one and they both play
the G 0 one of them has to be 0 right so
if this one 0 then x equals negative 1
or also definitely if this one 0 then
it's negative 3 they're prompts okay no
but - and they're so slightly more
difficult because that minus sign in
there means you need to take that into
account that pair of minus signs so we
want a pair of numbers that adds to
negative 1 and multiplies to negative 13
who can think of it yeah
ok very good
I want 5 and negative 6 you can think
immediately way you see 30 you can think
5 6 right but which one's negative then
you're going to here and you're like I
want to add them up and be negative 1 so
you want 6 to be negative right couldn't
speak up so this is my factorization
okay and that gives me my two solutions
okay by the way not that it matters a
huge amount it'll be right one way or
the other but if you want to try and get
these in order it's actually nicer to
have them in ascending order like this
so you have your smallest numbers first
but that's not a big deal okay number
three starts to get really involved
because it's remembering those first two
we call their monic quadratics because
there's not money which is what tricky
but still doable okay what am I gonna do
I still want a pair of numbers right
what pair of numbers are my after what
is a pair of numbers do someone else
what hasn't made anything you
though I'm very glad it made this often
yeah yeah it's then apparent numbers
that adds to negative 11
but multiplies not to - but to 24
okay so I 7 both well I'm thinking I
want I want negative 3 and negative
right because you're a big you 3
negative 8 that will give you the
negative 11 okay is that good so what I
do with this negative 3 and negative 8
like what do i where do I put those
numbers say again both the negative so
does that does that cause me any
problems that's gonna be okay
that's good okay so that's what gives me
the positive 24 right now in 1 & 2
because they're bought it I can take
that pair of numbers and I can chuck
them straight into this factorized fool
right but when it's not Manik yeah I
need to do something slightly different
the negative 3 negative 8 I'm gonna
break apart this middle term into minus
3x and minus 8x sorry I'm gonna write
that down 12x squared let's see here I
can write minus 3x first or I can write
minus 8x first which do you think
would've bet on - what would you try and
why don't we just try it because the
great thing about this is if we if we do
it wrong it's no big deal right we'll
just try again okay so off I've written
down minus 3 first and that equals 0 ok
let's see what happens when i pair it up
what factor can I take out of the first
pair I can take 3x out right and that
leaves you with here for X and minus 1
does that look promising
it does look Rosie doesn't it okay I
could have done the minus 8x with the
12x squared and then taken out 4x is
stared but then I'm going to get
something in here which is not going to
match up with my next one so in a big
deal you just stop and try again okay
here the fact I'm going to take out is I
want - - and I just want to I want minus
2 because this non Brad here the
constant just the the numeral I want it
to be negative right so that's going to
give me 4x minus 1
just like I was expecting now I've got
my pairs and so I can factorize okay
fantastic and we can again read off the
numbers here the solution to that
left-hand part if I make that left part
zero I'm gonna have two thirds very good
or 1/4 in there right you're starting to
get the hang of it great
let's move on to for now I'm gonna show
you a trick on this one because the
numbers end up being a bit bigger that
you have to work with them and it
becomes a bit harder to work out these
factors right so I want a pair of
numbers that adds tonight and multiplies
to negative right yeah but name is 70 I
don't know the factors of 70 like like
this right so I can think some of them
are obvious right but I want to make
sure that I get all of the so I know
which one's gonna be the useful one okay
so here's my uh my really handy trick
get your calculator out okay grab your
calculator out and your calculators but
to you ten eleven twelve what a
collective house so I recently
discovered this existed okay
seventy is the number that we want to
factorize we want to work out okay what
numbers could go into this that mod
that's the whole point of us so take
your calculator and punch seventy
display and then hit equals right so
that 70 is there you've Christian equals
now it's bottom right okay and the
button I'm after because I want factors
right I want to factorize this see you
might be able to see it just above the
degrees minutes seconds but you see that
in yellow it says fact which is short
for factor okay so since it's yellow you
press shift shift fact and then it tells
you that okay so 70 is equal to 2 times
5 times 7 now I want you to think all
the way back to you seven right what
this is and maybe you want to just write
this down on the side cuz so useful what
your calculator is just handing you is
called the prime factorization do you
guys not have that button on there
okay right now if you don't have it it's
no big deal you can still do this
process without this just like just like
I would okay with you know back in the
days when this calculated exist but for
those of you and a lot of you do because
this is the one that we sell let me show
you how this is useful what I'm gonna do
with this okay so first thing I already
see 2 times 5 times 7 to 5 and 7 there
are all factors of 17 so they're all
candidates they could be like one or
both of the numbers that I'm going to
use to pair up okay but those aren't the
only factors there are more than three
factors right for instance I've been you
know all Bubba's all the biz share at
least one factor in common namely one
right that's that's a fact but also
every combination of those numbers is
also a factor right so for example we
know that this is a multiple of 10 right
7 times 10 and I get 10 from 2 times 5
all right so 10 is also a factor I could
say there's a 5 times 17 s so that's 35
35 is also a factor is what wall can you
see what other combination can I use I
can get 2 by 7 right 2 by 7 which is 14
14 is also a factor okay now I don't
know about you some of them are really
obvious to me like okay it's an even
number that's obvious that's a multiple
of 10 that's obvious 14 not so obvious
right I mean you could work it out but
it doesn't just jump out at me okay now
that's particularly useful because we
look again come back to the original
question I want a pair of numbers that
adds to 9 and it multiplies to negative
17 okay which different by a difference
of 9 right well let's see here
7 times 10 are they off by 9 No uh what
okay by 9 they're fine you know a much
bigger number what else we got here - by
35
are they off by 9 it's not happening
right which pair do I want I want you
know that non-obvious one okay so 42
five of my actual numbers I want one of
them
it's as when I them together I want a
positive number so therefore if I want
70 I'm going fun five times that if me
negative 70 okay so now I've got my pair
of numbers now I know just like this
line how to break apart that plus 9x so
a question for what I got I've got a 2x
squared out the front this was an easy
one to choose which one am I going to
write first it's got to be the 14 right
14x minus 5x minus 35 and you okay with
that you see how I use those numbers
again sometimes when you have solving a
math problem the problem is so large
that you solve one part of it and then
you forget why you were solving that
part okay we've got that pair of numbers
here's where we're putting it okay can
we pair these up now what's the common
factor 2x very good when you take that
out that leaves you with x plus 7 good
okay what's the common factor here minus
5 right and that again leaves you with x
plus 7 which checks out okay so I'm
gonna factor down and in some senses
like that was really the hard part right
I think I've done the hard part but I
might as well finish off the question
solve it I'm gonna read two answers off
this off the left-hand side what number
am I gonna stick in there to get 0 5
onto 2 it enough and this was really
easy it's just negative 7 right happy
times I guess I would usually write that
first bit let me do okay so if you have
that factorize button
it's handy but it's not necessary it's
not necessary I think that like I said 2
is easy to see 10 is easy to see if 2
and 10 are both factors then 5 also has
to be a factor right so you can use your
calculator you're like what's 70 divided
by 5 and it'll tell you 14 okay